[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So to get
us kicked off today,
you're going to hear a keynote
from a mystery participant who
nobody has ever seen
before and you have not
met several times
over the course
of the past couple of days.
She also, though,
is so much more
than what she has been
doing for you so far.
And so much more than
what you will see
through the rest of the week.
One of my favorite people.
I'm going to do her
full bio, just that you
can see the wealth
of things that she's
done so far in her
career, and how excited we
are to have her here with us.
Jennie-- Jennie Magiera is
the chief program officer
for EdTech team.
Previously, in fact,
prior to about,
I don't know, a month ago,
she was the chief innovation
officer at Des Plains Public
School District 62 outside
of Chicago.
She was the digital
learning coordinator
for the Academy for Urban School
Leadership and a Chicago Public
Schools teacher.
Jennie uses her
classroom experience
to inform her work
supporting educators
to create new and
better opportunities
for their students.
She believes that despite the
many challenges facing schools
today, every classroom
can be a place for what
she calls adventures--
student-centered, passion-based,
experiential learning.
Her work centers around
acknowledging problems
and finding innovative
ways to navigate them so as
to allow teachers and students
to dive into these classroom
adventures.
Jennie is also passionate
about reimagining
professional learning,
as you can see here,
to facilitate more
relevant teacher support.
She has served on the
Technical Working Group
for the US Department of
Education's National Education
Technology Plan, and co-founded
various new conference
concepts, such as PLAYDATE.
She's been recognized
for her work
as a White House Champion
for Change, a Chicago Public
Schools Innovator of the Year,
a TEDx speaker, Golden Apple
Teacher of Distinction,
Apple Distinguished Educator,
Google for Education
Certified Innovator,
and featured on various programs
such as NBC's "Education
Nation," CSPAN's "Reimagining
Education," and NPR.
Whew, that's a lot.
Jennie also shares
her experience
taking risks in the
classroom and helping others
to feel comfortable doing the
same in her book, "Courageous
Adventures," which you
will all see on your desks
in front of you.
Some of you may also remember
Jennie from the amazing keynote
that she did about a month
ago at the ISTE Conference.
She had 6,000 educators
laughing and crying along
with her, including me in the
front row, wiping away tears.
We are truly honored
to have her join us
as part of this program team.
And I'm so excited
to have her be
your keynote speaker for today.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIE MAGIERA: All
right, I think I did it.
We'll find out in a moment.
All right, so this
morning I'm really
excited to have some
time with all of you
to just talk and to
think about what you're
getting into as coaches,
as principals supporting
this innovation and
transformation in your schools.
And so I want to begin
by telling you a story.
Yesterday, AT had
storytime with you
and he introduced you to
the venerable characters
of Miss Beyonce and
Principal Madonna,
but I want to go a little
bit more traditional today
and go back to one of
my favorite stories
from when I was a
child, "The Hobbit."
Anyone else read this
when they were a kid,
or read it with your kids?
Yay!
I have to just like call out
that this is the coaching
fellowship, and in,
like, the sequel,
there's like "The
Fellowship of the Rings,"
but we won't go down that road.
So for those of you who aren't
familiar with JRR Tolkien's
novel "The Hobbit," it
stars two main characters.
There's Gandalf the
Grey, who's a wizard.
And he's a plucky wizard.
He's got lots of jokes.
He wants to go on adventures.
And then you've got Bilbo
Baggins, who's a hobbit.
And essentially, what happens is
Gandalf knocks on Bilbo's door
and he's like, [KNOCKING NOISE],,
hey, what's up?
How's it going?
And Bilbo's like, ah, I'm
having a birthday party.
Leave me alone.
And Gandolf the
Grey says, "I'd like
to invite you on an adventure
that I'm arranging."
And I remember
reading this when I
was nine years old for
the very first time,
and thinking that this statement
was the most amazing quote I'd
ever read in a book before.
Because, first of all, I
had never heard someone
say that you could just
determine that you were
going to have an adventure.
Like I'm going to arrange a
nice little adventure for seven
and invite my friends.
And that you could have
people come with you.
And as I became an
educator, I thought, man,
wouldn't it be great if
every day, instead of lesson
planning, I could
arrange adventures
for my students to come along?
And so as the story goes,
eventually, Bilbo says yes.
And he goes on this adventure.
He goes out.
He gets his walking stick.
He meets a Gollum.
He gets a ring.
He fights a dragon.
He gets some gold.
He goes home and he
lives happily ever after.
Sorry, spoiler alert.
That's "The Hobbit."
So great.
That's the story
of "The Hobbit."
But with that being said,
there's a lot more to it
than a lot of us want to retell.
For example, in
that first scene,
when Gandalf the Grey knocks on
Bilbo Baggins's door and says,
I'm looking for someone to
share an adventure that I'm
arranging, he follows up
with, "it's very difficult
to find anyone."
And what's more is Bilbo
responds, "I should think so."
He tells them that
we're plain people,
we don't like going
on adventures.
They're nasty,
uncomfortable things.
And they make you
late for dinner.
And as I read this, it
really occurred to me
that this is so analogous
to my life as a coach,
as a school leader.
And I think about if I truly
want to invite my colleagues
and my students on
adventures, how often
do they say this back to me?
I literally told
teachers, when I'm like,
let's stay after and talk
about Google, they're like no.
It's going to make
me late for dinner.
Go away.
And so I want to think a
little bit about our teachers.
And specifically going
back to this analogy.
In the book "The
Hobbit," JRR Tolkien
describes hobbits as not
the adventuring type.
Bilbo Baggins says that
to Gandalf the Grey.
I'm not the adventuring type.
Now yesterday,
Jeff Duncan-Andrade
talked to us about a concept
that Claude Steele popularized
in his book "Whistling
Vivaldi," which by the way,
I have to plus one
that recommendation.
It's amazing.
Read it.
But he talks about stereotype
threat and the self-identity
that many of our
students have where
they believe the stereotypes
that society has given to them.
And then that then
becomes a psychological,
and sometimes in his book
he proves physiological,
barrier to achieve
and to be successful.
But I posit to you that
that happens to our teachers
as well.
There's stereotype
threat that our teachers
face in their own self-identity
of what they can accomplish.
And as coaches and
principals, it's
our role to help them overcome
that stereotype threat.
Now, Bilbo Baggins said, I'm
not the adventuring type.
But Gandalf the
Grey, his coach, was
able to help him overcome
that stereotype threat
and see a new self-identity for
himself so that he could go on
to fight Gollums, get rings, get
riches, go home, fight dragons.
And this reminds me of
a really amazing TED
Talk by a Nigerian author
named Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie.
Has anyone seen this before?
Oh, it's so great.
So what I'd like
for all of you to do
is I'm just going to get
off and take the next 18
minutes to watch this.
I'll be right back.
JK.
So in this talk, Chimamanda
talks about something
called the single story.
The single story
is what she says
is the single story that is told
about a certain group of people
over and over again
until it becomes
all anyone knows about them.
As a Nigerian
middle class woman,
she encountered the
single story of Africa
when she came to the United
States for university
and realized that people had one
understanding of her society,
and her culture,
and this continent
as one giant country that's a
village of barefoot children.
She said, this is crazy.
This is the single story.
And she goes on to say
something about stereotypes.
She says "stereotypes
aren't wrong.
They're just incomplete."
And as educators, I started
to think about that.
And I said, what are the single
stories and the stereotypes
that are then propagating
the stereotype
threat in our organizations
and in our industry?
So today I want to look
at the single stories
that we have about ourselves
as teachers, as coaches,
as principals.
The single stories that we have
about each other and our peers.
And consider the
untold stories that we
need to be considering
as we go in
to support our colleagues in
transforming our communities.
So I have three
stories for you today
that we're going
to talk through.
The first one is the single
story of our resistant
colleagues and the untold
story of friendly dragons.
Now, when I first became
a coach, I was resistant.
I was a classroom
teacher who was working
on one-to-one iPads in my room.
And I always knew that I
wanted to be a teacher.
I wanted to be a teacher because
I knew I got long way better
with kids than adults.
It's a lot less frustrating
when a third grader's
throwing a temper tantrum.
But like when a
40-year-old is, it's like,
you're a grown person.
Let's do this.
So when I became a coach for the
very first time, it validated
my single story of what life
as an administrator would be,
which is the first time
I walked into a room
to support a group of
teachers on one-to-one iPads,
they literally ran away from me.
And I don't mean that
at all metaphorically.
I walked into the staffroom
and they looked at me,
and they're like, oh
no, it's the iPad lady.
And they all walked
out the back door.
They're like peace.
Nope, nope.
And they hid.
And I don't know
where they went,
but they would not hang with me.
And it was constantly
that I was physically
chasing people to support them.
And always, it was like Jennie,
I get it, you're excited.
You love this iPad stuff.
But I don't have time for this.
And it was a lot of yes buts.
And it really began to
weigh on my heart and soul,
because I truly had seen
and witnessed firsthand
how technology could
transform the opportunities
that my students could
have in front of them.
I saw how my students who
needed the most support
had access to it by having
the access to the world's
information, to each other,
to amplify their voices.
And people were
running from that.
And I got really frustrated.
And I gotta say,
I was resentful.
And I started thinking
about something
I'd learned in grad school.
How many of you are familiar
with Everett Rogers's
"Diffusion of Innovation?"
So Everett Rogers
was a sociologist.
And in the '60s, he developed
this bell curve model
for organizations.
And it's how quickly innovation
is adapted in organizations.
And he said that the top 16% are
innovators and early adopters,
folks who are going to jump on
board quickly and get geeked up
about these things.
The middle 68% can be convinced.
But that last 16%, he
called them laggards,
are very resistant and
refuse to get on board.
And while I saw this, and
my logical brain said, OK,
that's true, I thought
it was more like 90%
were laggards in my schools.
It was like all of them were
just like, no, leave us alone.
And going back to
our metaphor, I
began to think about
this as the innovators
and the early adopters in my
buildings were the wizards,
were the Gandalfs who were like,
let's go on adventures, yay,
flip grid.
And everyone else
were the laggards.
They were our hobbits.
And so what I want
to think about--
and sometimes I even felt
like they were dragons.
Like they weren't even on it.
So then I really started
to reach deep back
into what I could do, and
did some soul searching.
And I remembered this story
that my mother used to tell me.
There was this painting that
hung over my parents' bed
in my childhood home.
I don't have a photo, a
nice photo of it anymore.
This is when we were
packing up their house,
so you can see it right there.
And it's a painting of a
cliff on an island called
Jeju Do on the south of Korea.
And this is Dragon Rock.
And my mother would
tell me this fable
about Dragon Rock all the time.
Which, side note disclaimer,
I found out as an adult
when I actually visited
there and saw the placard
that her story was
completely made up and false.
[LAUGHTER]
But she's my mom, so she
gets to make up mom facts.
And it really works for this.
And it inspired me, so I'm
telling you this fake story.
Feel free to use it.
Now, according to this
fake mom fact story,
there was a village at the
bottom of this mountain.
And the villagers truly
had a good feeling.
They were getting along.
They were eating.
Like life was OK.
They were like that bottom level
of Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
like food, shelter water.
Nailed it.
Got it.
But they knew it
could be better.
And there was something at
the top of this mountain
that they knew if they could get
to it could change their world.
It could make life wonderful for
every person in that village.
And so they decided to go up
the mountain and try and get it.
But every time they'd get almost
to the top of the mountain,
they'd get stopped by a dragon.
And this dragon would fight
them and would attack them.
And they'd come
running back down.
And so they began to give up.
They're like, we can't get
to the top of the mountain.
There's a dragon up there.
I guess we'll
just-- this is fine.
It doesn't suck too bad.
Let's just continue.
Until one day
someone decided no.
No, I know we can do this.
I know we can be better.
I'm going to go to the
top of the mountain.
So he starts climbing
up the mountain.
He gets to the dragon.
And right as he's about
to fight the dragon with--
I don't know what he
would fight-- taekwondo,
he sees on the dragon's
arm that there's thorns
all wrapped around his arm.
So he puts down his fists
and he takes the thorns,
and he puts some salve on
it, and he helps fix it.
And as the dragon's wounds
begin to heal, the dragon slowly
transforms into the friendly
villager that had been missing
for years, that they'd assumed
had been eaten by said dragon.
And the first villager
said, hey, Steve.
Well, I guess his name--
Sunkjung, it's great to see you.
What's going on?
And Sunkjung,
says, I don't know.
This is a made up name
for this made up story.
So Sunkjung, says, I
have been stuck here
for years with these thorns.
And every time
people come up, they
try and battle me to get around
me to get to this other thing.
And no one would
help me until you.
And then once his
wounds were healed,
he helped the villager
get to the top
and achieve his goal as well.
And my mother would tell
me this story because she
would say to me, Jennifer--
she called me
Jennifer, not Jennie--
Jennifer, when people
are trying to fight you,
and when people are
arguing with you
about what you are trying
to achieve, why don't you
stop arguing with
them and listen
to what their problem is first?
And if you can find the
kindness in your heart
to help them solve their problem
first, even if it doesn't help
you with your
problem, you will be
amazed by how much
they will do for you.
And as coaches
and as principals,
I really think that
this is helpful for us.
I told you guys the other day,
I am a recovering district
administrator.
I was a slave to
the board goals.
Everything I did was
like, how does that
relate to the board goals?
That's a different story.
So I understand that
when I come into schools,
both as a building
leader, as a coach,
as a district
administrator, we really
want our kids to achieve to what
is the vision of our district.
But when I put that
on pause for a moment
and first helped my teachers
with what they really
needed, their highest
hierarchy of need,
they would jump over moons
to help us with our goals.
And so I think that as we
see these resistant dragons,
we can find that
they could truly
be wizards if we
give them a chance
and help them unwrap
their own thorns.
So those resistant
colleagues that many of you
have encountered,
I'm sure you can
think of the hobbits
in your midst,
think about how
you can engage them
and find out what
their stories are.
Find out their untold stories
and their untold challenges.
And think about how we can make
time in our very busy schedule
to address those on
an individual level,
just as we would do
for our students,
so that we can find
those friendly dragons.
My second story for you
is about the single story
we choose to tell the
world and the untold story
of our inner selves.
Now, as leaders and
coaches, and we're
looking at this
hierarchy of needs
and this diffusion
of innovation scale,
we can look at the
people who are always
saying, I can't,
and like I said,
we can be a little bit
frustrated with them.
But I really want to unpack
that "I can't" for a moment.
That "I can't" come
from a place of identity
for a lot of our folks.
My husband, Jim, is an attorney.
Boo.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you were to meet
him at the grocery store,
and you were waiting
in line, and you
got to chatting with him,
you'd learn a lot about Jim.
You'd find out that he loves
to barbecue and smoke ribs.
We have-- I live in a
little apartment in Chicago
with a tiny front porch.
And we have five grills.
You would find out that he's
a huge Chicago Cubs fan.
And he said that
last year when they
won the World
Series was the best
day of his entire life, which
is really sad, because one
of the days of his
life he married me.
[LAUGHTER]
But you would not find
out he's an attorney.
And the reason why you
would not find out he's
an attorney is because, as
Jim says, being a lawyer
is just what I do for a job.
It's not who I am.
But if you and I were to meet,
within the first five minutes,
the first thing you would
know about me is that I'm
an educator, because being an
educator is not just what I do,
it's who I am as a person.
It is intrinsically
related to my identity.
And so when we're
asking our colleagues
to change, and to do
something different,
and to change the entire
definition of what it looks
like to teach and
learn in a classroom,
we're asking them to change
part of their identity
and how they exist
in their schools.
And that leads to fear.
And that leads to disbelief.
And that identity
is something we
need to be very careful to
acknowledge and to talk about.
Speaking of identity, I recently
came across this Facebook post
about Facebook, funny enough.
It was like Facebook inception.
Right here.
Don't let Facebook
make you miserable.
And I was on Facebook
at the moment,
and I was like, I am
definitely feeling miserable
right now by Facebook.
This is free, let's
click on this.
And this is by a
journalist named
Seth Stephens-Davidowitz, who
works for "The New York Times."
And he basically says that
all of your friends and family
are dirty, awful liars.
Does anyone have
a friend or family
who seems to always be on
vacation, all the time?
They're like constantly
living hashtag best life ever.
And you're like, god,
I'm always at my school
and you're always
at like Barbados.
How is this possible?
Do you not work?
And so he got frustrated
by that feeling
of looking at social
media and seeing
this version of his
friends and family
that seemed to be, first
of all, unbelievable.
But also like incredibly
happy, while his life looked
dreary and depressing.
So he decided to
do some research.
He pulled up some analytics
and he looked up some data.
And he was able to
find the following.
For example, Americans spend
six times the amount of hours
in a week washing
dishes as playing golf.
And yet, they tweet
about golf three times
more often than washing dishes.
They're not like, man,
this Dawn soap is great,
hashtag best dish ever.
Like it's not happening.
[LAUGHTER]
Additionally, the budget hotel
in Las Vegas, Circus-Circus,
has the same number of rooms as
the luxury hotel, The Bellagio.
And yet, people check
into the Bellagio
six times as often on
Facebook than Circus-Circus.
They're like, man, this
gold toilet is great.
I don't know.
I've never been there.
Do they have gold toilets?
AUDIENCE: No.
JENNIE MAGIERA: OK.
We're in education,
though, so let's take it
back to some reading.
Let's look at what are our
colleagues and friends reading?
How many of you are
familiar with the periodical
"The Atlantic?"
OK.
They write some articles,
like 50 greatest inventions.
OK, love it.
And then there's also
the esteemed, renowned,
and historic
"National Enquirer,"
which is like
Skynet is a reality,
Terminator's definitely
going to happen.
Please go home and
smash your computers.
Now, does anyone want to guess--
well, let's first say this.
The "National Enquirer"
sells three times the number
of copies every year as
"The Atlantic," all right?
Does anyone want to
guess how many more
times your friends
and family are
claiming to read "The Atlantic"
over the "National Enquirer?"
AUDIENCE: Three times.
JENNIE MAGIERA: Six.
Three times more.
Anyone else?
10 times more.
I have to turn this on
its side to show you--
45 times the number of people
claim to read "The Atlantic"
over the "National Enquirer."
Now, let's break that down.
They're like, yeah man,
I read that article.
It was great.
There's inventions, and
there were 50 of them,
and they were great.
You didn't read it.
You just pretended
to on Facebook.
So here's the thing,
Seth Stephens-Davidowitz
also has this quote.
It's a maxim that's used in a
lot of different places, which
is "don't compare your insides
to other people's outsides."
And then he goes on to add
to that maxim, "of course,
this advice is
difficult to follow,
because we never see
other people's insides."
There's always
this false reality
that people are putting
out of perfection and ease.
So he said, how can
I break this down?
And he decided to
use-- wait for it--
Google.
Now, he decided to look
at the top five statements
that people seem to be making on
Facebook, which is, I'm always
on vacation, I'm
always having brunch,
I'm always taking
selfies, and I'm always
having hashtag best life ever.
At this time, he
also looked up what
the top five autofills for
the search "I'm always"
was on Google.
And this is public
data aggregate
from across the world of
what people are actually
looking up for "I always."
And what he found at
the time of this article
was that people are not always
on vacation, having brunch,
taking selfies, and
living best life ever.
They are feeling tired,
have to pee, have diarrhea,
and they're bloated.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, I have to acknowledge
that these are not
mutually exclusive.
People can be on vacation
and have GI issues.
But the thing is--
[LAUGHTER]
--there's a difference between
the story we're sharing.
So then I decided to ask
myself, am I guilty of this?
Am I guilty of hashtag
best life ever lying?
And so I looked at
my own Facebook page.
And I'm like geothermal
pool in Iceland,
hashtag best life ever.
Indoor sky diving with
friends, best life ever.
Sitting with my husband by
a mountain, best life ever.
Mountains are a big deal
for people in Chicago.
We don't have
anything like that.
And I thought back to what
Seth Stephens-Davidowitz was
saying about comparing your
insides to other people's
outsides.
And so I decided
that I was going
to start trying to be a
lot more open with my life
and share my insides a bit more.
Now, this is a story
that I've started
sharing with more people
over the past couple months
actually because
of this article.
So I'm going to talk to a
of you about it as well.
For the past six
years, my husband and I
have been having
a lot of issues.
Not maritally.
I like him.
I like his BBQ.
Go Cubs.
But we've been trying
to start a family.
And it's really frustrating
when you spend your entire life
trying not to start a family and
then you decide to and then you
can't.
And so for the past six
years, we've been struggling.
And when you're also
struggling with something,
it seems like it's
easy for everyone else.
And so the more and the
longer that we were struggling
to have a family, I was
like, everyone around me
was pregnant constantly.
Like chew, sneeze,
you're pregnant.
Like how is this happening?
Oh my gosh.
There's something wrong with me.
I'm so embarrassed.
And I didn't want
to talk about it.
And so I started to
get really frustrated.
And I stopped wanting to try.
I was like, it's
just not for us, Jim.
We're not the baby
making people, I guess.
Like we'll just get over it.
Let's get more dogs.
And then finally,
we decided to go
to the next step for treatment.
And I was terrified.
I was scared.
And I wanted to
ask for help, but I
didn't know anyone who was going
through fertility treatment.
I didn't know if it was what
I wanted to do spiritually,
mentally, physically.
But I didn't have
anyone to ask for help,
because my friends are all
like, sneezy rabbits who
get pregnant immediately.
So I decided to
put it on Facebook.
And I asked my husband,
are you OK with this?
And he said, it's fine.
And I posted this
post on Facebook.
And I shared with my
friends and family
that we were having a
hard time, and that we
were going to try something
new, and that I was scared.
And if anyone, by the grace
of God, had gone through this,
could they please
reach out to me?
And I thought, God,
my friends are all
going to think I'm
broken and this is awful.
But within one hour I had over
288 likes and 75 comments.
And what's more is
in the next 24 hours,
over 80 friends
and family called,
texted, or showed up at
my door to talk to me.
And to tell me,
you're not alone.
And you might have thought you
were the only one struggling
and you were the only
one going through this,
but I'm going through this too.
And I had to go through
this to have all of my kids.
And these kids, we
had to get help.
And you know what, we don't
even like them that much--
[LAUGHTER]
--so if you want one,
I have some spares
to donate to the cause.
Now, the thing that was really
amazing for me about this
was that I had spent
so long in the dark,
isolating myself in my struggle,
because I saw the single story
that my friends chose to share
to the world of the ease it
was for them to
overcome challenges
and to meet that goal.
And I started
thinking about this
as we are building up our
communities and our schools.
And we're trying
to inspire people
to overcome a lot of challenges
and hurdles to innovate.
And thinking about how
teaching is an identity
for many of our colleagues.
And we're asking them to change
what teaching looks like.
And so I started
to think back, do I
need to do a better job
of sharing my insides
and my journeys to innovation?
Do people look at
what we've done
and they see the tech
coaches amongst you,
and they were like, oh,
it's so easy for him.
It's so easy for her.
I could never do that.
She sneezes and uploads
a video to YouTube.
Like I could never do that.
And so I thought about my
story, about how I was a teacher
and I was doing my thing.
And I had my computers
in my classroom.
Computers meaning three.
And it looked-- that's it.
And it took 18
minutes to turn on.
And they literally smoked
when you turned them on.
And my kids would be
like, is this safe?
I'm like, don't worry about it.
Do more Accelerated Reader.
It's great.
And I remember my first big tech
was this overhead calculator.
And I put it on my overhead.
And my kids were like, whoa!
It's clear.
You can see it.
It was gnarly, right?
You're like, yes!
And I put it in its little
bed every night, in its foam.
It was great.
So for me-- for me--
AUDIENCE: It was high quality.
JENNIE MAGIERA: Yes, it was.
I'm not going to lie.
I still have it.
I really love it.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't have an overhead
projector anymore,
but I kept the calculator.
So I was really
excited when they--
Chicago Public Schools had
announced a grant for iPads.
And I was like, woo!
And to be clear,
iPads were announced
to the world in April, 2010.
And they announced
the grant in June.
It was like the first time
CPS was the first in anything.
But I didn't know
what an iPad was.
I thought was like a giant
phone that couldn't make calls.
But I knew I wanted one.
So I applied for this
grant with my team.
And somehow, we got it.
And I was so excited.
And I was like, yay,
I'm getting iPads.
This is going to be great.
And the cart came like three
days before the kids came.
And I was pretty
pumped about it.
But really, it turned more
into like this like this.
My life was a hot mess.
Like I thought I knew
what was going on.
And I was like, yay, I'm
going to change the world
with technology.
And it was like,
no, I want to bury
the iPads in the
back of the school
and pretend they got lost.
It was awful.
And the thing was I was
spending a lot of time googling,
like how do you use
iPads in fourth grade?
And this was 2010.
And so nobody knew
what an iPad was.
So I had to change
to technology.
And a lot of people were telling
me to flip my classroom and use
videos to differentiate.
And so I started doing that.
And the story that I
would tell the world
is I'm using videos
for differentiation.
I'm meeting every
kid where they're at,
personalized learning, winning.
And a lot of people who
have heard about the work
that I've done in Chicago,
my colleagues in the network,
are like yeah,
Jennie's that iPad lady
who does flipped classroom.
It's so easy for her.
But the story I didn't tell them
was about the hot mess part.
And I've started to try and
narrate that more, to know
yeah, I've done these things.
But the first time
I tried to do this,
I did create a really
epic video about volume
of a rectangular pyramid.
And I did come in on
Saturday and sync it
to all my kids' iPads.
And they did come in on
Monday, and they did put
on their headphones,
and they did hit Play.
And they were silent
for three full minutes.
And I thought, ah,
truly I am a wizard,
for I have made 39 fourth
graders silent for three
minutes.
But what I didn't tell
people was that at that point
a little girl giggled, and
then a little boy giggled.
And I was like, hmm, funny.
Volume isn't usually comedic.
So I went over and I was
looking at their iPad.
I'm like, what's going on.
And then, to my horror, I
realized that I had not,
in fact, synced the video that
I had painstakingly created.
But instead, the
2010 raunchy comedy
classic "Hot Tub Time Machine."
[LAUGHTER]
And they have been watching
it for three minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
So I was like, well,
it's been real.
I'm definitely
getting fired now.
Goodbye forever.
But here's the thing.
I talked to my principal.
I had a really interesting
conversation with her.
I had lots of very interesting
conversations with parents.
And it was hard for me
and I wanted to give up.
But I had a coach.
I had a coach who
told me, don't worry.
It's OK to make mistakes.
Keep trying.
Just don't do it
again next time.
And as coaches,
what I really want
to tell you is great about
that coach that I had was
she was always vulnerable.
And she always
showed me her warts.
And she always showed
me her inner self.
And when she made a mistake,
she was really transparent
about it.
And anytime I was
trying something hard,
she told me about
her failures when
she tried it the first time.
And she made that
path so approachable
for me to walk down.
And she was not perfect.
And that was the
best thing about her.
And so as we think about the
single story we tell the world,
really think about the
inner story of yourself,
the untold stories that we
may not share all the time.
And think about how
to create a path that
is approachable for all of the
people who follow behind you.
No, my final story for you
is about the single story
of teachers.
We've talked a lot about
the identity of teachers
and how you might
see that as part
of this existential
version of you.
But I also want to think about
the untold story of wizards.
And I want to start
off with Mr. P.
Mr. P is a teacher that
I coached in Chicago.
He's a middle
school math teacher.
There he is right
there, lifelike drawing
of Mr. P. Mr. P came to me
with a problem of practice.
He said, Jennie, I
really need some help.
My kids hate math.
And as a fellow math teacher,
oh, it just broke my heart.
He's like, I don't think there's
anything I can do about it.
If a kid's going to hate math,
a kid's going to hate math.
Maybe they're a reading person.
And I said, come on, Patrick,
you know better than that.
You know that we're not like
a math person or a reading
person.
We just have to
help them understand
the content in a way
that makes sense to them.
So he said, my kids hate math.
And I said, well,
I'm going to give you
a book then, which was, like,
you want me to read a book
and they hate math.
This doesn't make any sense.
I'm like, don't worry.
It's a book about math.
And it's actually
by a local educator.
His name is Matt Vaudrey.
And he wrote a book called
"The Classroom Chef."
And I said, the
thing that we can
do to help kids love math
is to find the story in it.
To find the way to narrate this.
So let's think about a
different way to approach it.
And we looked at the
book and we found
a lot of different examples.
And as Mr. P was looking through
the book, his eyes lit up.
And he was like, oh, I
know what I want to do.
I was like, what did you find?
Tell me more.
And he had found a
chapter about mullets.
Now, the problem
was he was thinking
about how to use mullets
in his classroom,
but his kids didn't
know what a mullet was.
It's 2015 at this time.
Mullets are not the most
popular hairstyle anymore.
And when you Google it,
this is the definition,
the number one
definition is a fish.
And so he was thinking, what
is the definition of mullet?
How can I show my kids?
So he began to find images.
And of course, there is
the dictionary definition
of a mullet, which is
business in the front
and party in the back.
And in the book,
"The Classroom Chef,"
Matt Vaudrey has cooked
up a way to teach
middle school math via mullets.
And that is through the very
important mathematical theorem
of the mullet ratio.
Now, the mullet
ratio is one's ratio
of party in the back to
business in the front.
And to visualize this
for you, it's as such.
So one measures the party
to business in centimeters
and then creates a ratio
where the numerator is party
and the denominator is business.
And Patrick decided to
take us into his classroom
and try it out.
He found some images of mullets
and he gave them to his kids.
And they began to determine
the mullet ratio--
[LAUGHTER]
--and they found that it varies.
And that it's not age defining.
And you know, young, old can
have a pretty strong mullet
ratio.
And they went
around the classroom
and they began to
find these ratios.
He found out a lot
about his students,
and he read a lot about Matt
Vaudrey's experience as well.
For example, students
can love math.
You just have to give them
the right entree point, which
is apparently '80s hairstyles.
And that people
like Billy Ray Cyrus
are always dreamy
to teenage girls.
This is an actual worksheet
that was turned in to a teacher.
[LAUGHTER]
Now Mr. P decided to
take this further.
So his kids were
studying ratios.
And then next they were looking
at linear relationships.
And he decided, I
want to continue
an entire thematic unit
on mullets for math.
So he decided to
think about how they
could graph a one-to-one
party to business line.
And then he took modern
celebrities to find,
is the mullet surreptitiously
coming back into style?
And he found that it might be.
He determined that
there's something
called the one-to-one
proportional line, which
is the Obama Bieber line.
2010 Justin Bieber
and Barack Obama
had a perfect one-to-one ratio
hairstyle mapped as P to B
right here.
And then you can see Miley
and Harry Styles are all
mapped along this continuum.
Now, the thing about Mr. P was
that he had started to give up.
He had started to
say, I don't know if I
want to be a teacher anymore.
Every day I come and teach
these seventh graders.
They hate it.
They don't do their homework.
And he just needed
to look at this
from a different perspective.
He needed a chance
to inject that fun.
And he had the single story
of himself as a math teacher.
And the single story he had
of himself as a math teacher
was his math teacher when
he was in seventh grade.
And what his coach was
able to do for him--
it was me-- was help him say
that your untold story is
your own and you don't have
to emulate the single story
of another teacher.
You can be yourself.
You can find your own
identity in your classroom.
And if you have fun and
you enjoy being there,
perhaps your kids will be too.
And so Mr. P was able to go from
hobbit to wizard and to find
that inner wizard in himself.
Now, this last teacher
I want to tell you about
is Miss R, Lindsay Rose.
And Lindsay Rose was a
teacher in my building.
And her problem, her practice
was that her students
were never on task.
And they were
constantly disengaged.
They were constantly
playing around.
And so what we
decided to do was take
a look at what
they were focusing
on instead of, again, math.
Jeff Duncan-Andrade
told us yesterday
that our kids are
coming to school
with a litany of other
stories and narratives
that are going on in their
head, other challenges
that they're facing other than
linear regression and ratio.
And in the case of
Lindsay Rose's students,
the challenges that
they were facing
was the community
that they lived in.
How many of you have
been to Chicago before?
Yay!
How many of you have
been to the South Shore
neighborhood of Chicago
at 103rd and Exchange.
I know, you work there.
A few of you.
Yes.
Now, for those of you who
raised your hand, Sarah, Rachel,
you know that probably there's
a lot of really great things
about South Shore.
It's a beautiful lakefront.
There is the stable where the
Chicago Police Department's
horses are held.
There's a golf course.
But if you Google
South Shore, what
you're going to find in
the news are these types
of articles about gun
violence and drug deals
and the number of gang activity
happening in that neighborhood.
It is the number one gun
per capita area of Chicago.
It was so bad that
the local media
started referring to it directly
as Terror Town instead of South
Shore.
And the single story
that was being propagated
in the mass media was that it
was a dangerous place to live,
you shouldn't be there, and we
need to clean up the streets
because they're gang ridden.
And everyone there
is a terrible person.
And the kids were
really frustrated.
They were frustrated to have
boot prints on their homework
coming to school because
the police had busted down
their door the day before.
They were frustrated
that every time they
turned on the television,
it was something negative
about their community.
They were frustrated that nobody
was telling their true story.
And so Lindsay Rose said, I now
understand why my kids are not
engaged in math.
What can we do?
So we decided to
do something crazy.
She took the book, "The
House on Mango Street,"
by Sandra Cisneros,
and she decided
to read an excerpt of it
to her class every day.
Have any of you read this book?
Really great mentor text.
And what she did was she had her
kids use the Cisneros's words
to think about, how
could they find a way
to tell the
counter-narrative to what
they were seeing in the news?
Now mind you, she was doing
all of this during math class.
But because she decided
to take this risk,
and I was able to work with her
to feel comfortable in doing
it, we were able to
get principal support
to give her five minutes a
day to work with her students.
And at the end of
every day, we said,
this doesn't lead
to a math standard,
but we believe by giving
our students a chance
to express themselves
during this period,
to build this relationship,
to talk through these issues,
it's going to allow them to be
better focused during the day.
And so the principal said,
I'm willing to give you
this chance.
And so I'm really
glad that there
are 50 principals
in this room who
can be there to give that space
to take risks in classrooms.
Because here's
what happened next.
The students wrote
this counter-narrative.
And they used social
media to share it out
with all of the major
news outlets in Chicago.
The "Chicago Sun-Times," the
"Tribune," NBC, ABC, NPR.
And it was picked up by
every single one of them.
What's more is the "Chicago
Sun-Times" sent a news truck
and media crew
down to the school,
to Bradwell School
of Excellence,
to record the sixth
graders telling the story
from their own point of view.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We saw your news
trucks and cameras here,
and we read your
article, "Six shot
in South Shore laundromat
and another mass
shooting in Terror Town."
- We saw the news
reporters with fancy suits
in front of our laundrymat.
- You spent 24 hours here,
but you really don't know us.
- Those who don't know us think
this is a poor neighborhood,
with those abandoned buildings
with the wood covering
the windows and broken doors.
- Those who don't know us
saw the police on the corner
and think that we're
all violence and drugs.
- They see the candy wrappers
and empty juice bottles
and think we don't care.
- Uneducated, jobless thieves.
You'll be scared of
these heartless people.
- When you see us coming,
you might hurry up and run
to your cars and lock the door.s
- Then speed down these
streets at 60 miles per hour
like you're on a highway trying
to get out of this ghetto.
- We want to know us.
We aren't afraid.
We know that man at the corner.
He works at the store and
gives us free Lemonheads.
- Those girls jumping rope are
Precious, Anaya, and Nevaeh.
- The people in
suits are not going
to funerals, but to church.
- That little creepy dog is
[INAUDIBLE],, Lamar's dog.
- We are the kids who fly on
crates so we can shoot hoops.
- When the sun
shines here, it's not
Got saying he wants to burn us.
But he sees us all
with bright futures.
- Those who know us look at the
ones who want to go to college,
not the ones who dropped out.
- If you lived here, you'd
here this laughter and chatter
from the group of
girls on the corner
who are best friends and
really care about each other.
- Do you see the smile
on the cashier's face
when the kids walk in?
Why?
Because this neighborhood
is filled with love.
- This isn't Chiraq.
This is home.
This is us.
[END PLAYBACK]
JENNIE MAGIERA:
For the first time,
the students had
a chance to tell
the world about their untold
story of their community.
And this teacher, Miss
Rose, she had this in her
the entire time.
I was her coach.
I helped her to get
the materials together.
I helped her to find a book.
I helped her to feel
confident to do it.
But this was all Lindsay.
And the thing that I
want you to think about
as you're going
back to your schools
and working with
your teachers is
that as coaches, as
principals, we're
there to help our
colleagues be the best
versions of themselves.
That this is all
in them already.
Miss Rose was already a wizard.
She just needed someone
to unlock that in her
and to give her the freedom and
permission to take that risk.
So as we think about the
single story of teachers,
know that all of our teachers
are secretly inner wizards.
And as coaches, as
principals, it's our duty.
And what we truly hope is going
to come out of this coaching
fellowship event is
that you are going
to find the tools to bring
out those inner wizards
in your teachers.
So thinking about Mr. P and
finding his inner wizard,
thinking about Miss Rose
and her inner wizard,
and thinking about all
the other teachers who
are in your schools who may be
acting like hobbits or dragons,
but truly are wizards, my
call to action for all of you
is to think.
When you go home,
how are you going
to use what you've
learned here this week,
the connections you've
made with each other
to inspire the people
in your buildings
and cultivate the
wizards in your school?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]